une place péri non encore en aménagement
un marché temporaires en attendant la
réhabilitation du marché couvert très
fréquenté de fort-de-france en travaux
des travaux qui génère nuisances sonores
poussières et autres pollutions mais
c'est pour la bonne cause
l'opération coeur de ville a débuté dans
la capitale bien avant que le
gouvernement n'accorde cette enveloppe
de 5 milliards que 222 ville devront se
partager la chiffrer globalement le
projet à 200 millions d'euros dans 162
millions de financements publics et 30
me portés par des partenaires privés sur
des projets pour briser nous allons
signer lundi matin la convention avec
les acteurs donc de l'état les bailleurs
sociaux et chambre de commerce chambre
des métiers la cacem donc tous les
partenaires du projet note le maire va
présider un comité de projet qui va
déterminer les projets retenus et à
mettre 9 chaque année un financement qui
n'est toujours pas versé sur le compte
de la mairie
et ce ne sont pas les projets qui
manquent parmi eux la reprise des voies
de la rue de la liberté et la venue des
caraïbes un plan de propreté la
modernisation des toilettes publiques et
l'embellissement de la fontaine guesdon
des projets que didier laguerre compte
bien exposé au président de la
république lors de sa visite
je veux profiter pour lui parler de nos
projets d'une autre que les attentes et
besoins de la ville pour parler aussi
zone franche urbaine pour parler
financement de l'activité économique et
de l'activité commerciale du paradis
aussi des problématiques de descente et
cukor encore que vous dit la martinique
et puis un sujet brûlant d'actualité
c'est celui de la la fonction qui est
prévue sur les ménages martin cas pour
financer des projets martin
le financement de l'opération coeur de
ville s'étale sur cinq ans avec
fort-de-france lamentait fait également
partie des 222 villes retenues par le
ministère de la cohésion des territoires